Jo Coburn: *is this going to transform
people's lives inthese areas?*
Gary: well I mean if I take £15 off you and then
give you £2.80 is that going totransform your life?
these guys found £2.8billion to give to local councils
in thelast 3 years they've given £700billion to the rich
*I know you made...* 250 times as much! listen
is it levelling up if Igive a poor person £2.80&
I give a rich person £250? No...sorry £700!
250 times as much, listenthis government has
resided over the largest and fastest ever increase
in inequality in the history of the country and
the most Orwellian thing you've ever heard;
they call that 'levelling up'
*what'd you say?*
okay let's talk about what I
learned from going on the BBC
okay for those of you who haven't seen it I
did my first live BBC appearance last week
on Thursday 19th of Jan on politics live um if
you want to see it we'll put a link to the show
in the description on BBC iPlayer um we'll also
put a link to like a reel of my highlights that
someone's posts up on YouTube so if you want
you can check that out um first thing to say
is that basically the reason that we've had
this opportunity to go on bigger shows like
this is because of the growth of this channel
and all the other social media that we have so
thank you to you for everyone who subscribed
tothis channel to all the other channels Twitter,
Facebook, Instagram, TikTok... people who've shared
the videos who've encouraged other people to to
watch and to get involved because it's that growth
that has enabled us to go on things like the BBC
and to spread the message further so thank you
the second thing I want to talk about is basically
what I learned from doing
the show because I think that
from what I saw on that show it's made me
realize there are some ways that we could
communicate in a way that is a bit more
aggressive a bit clearer and could really
hold the government to account and get more
people to realize the importance of what we
are doing which is trying to reduce wealth
inequality to prevent this economic collapse
so when I went on the show what I really wanted
to do and this would be no surprise to people
who've watched the channel from the beginning
is really highlight the enormous amount of
money that has gone from the government to
the richest since the beginning of Covid
that was the reason we started this channel
from the very from the very beginning of Covid
I realized that there would be an enormous transfer
of cash from the government to the rich that would
lead to a big increase in government debt which
would mean we'd have things like austerity and a
big increase in cash accumulation by the richest
leading to inflation and cost of living crisis
we're seeing those things now something needs to
be done about it what always frustrates me is that
every day on the news especially in the economic
news there tends to be a fixation whenever some
small amount of money is changing hands that day
in the meantime this enormous amount of money that
has gone to the rich is completely ignored so in
the clip you saw at the beginning of this video I
was asked you know what do you think about the 2.8
billion pounds that the government is giving to
fund local services this is after they have cut
local service funding by 15 billion pounds and
transferred 700 billion pounds to the rich I
think it's really key to understand that this
enormous amount of money that's gone to the
richest is at the very heart of our economic
crisis I think it's also important to understand
that that amount of money is so much bigger
than basically any individual problem we
have now even when the government needed
to deal with the energy price crisis the
costing of that was about 40 or 50 billion
pounds which is a lot in terms of government
funding but the amount that has gone from the
government to the richest in the last three
years is 700 billion pounds enormously more so
what I want you to know is that this amount
of money that has gone to the rich is much
much bigger than basically anything you hear on
the news so whenever you see whenever you hear
any amount of money such as the £2.8 billion
going into local funding compare it to the
£700 billion and realize it's not even nearly
enough to fix the massive increase inequality
second thing that I wanted to point out is
when I confronted the conservative minister
who was on the show I said to her you know
yourgovernment's given out 700 billion pounds
did you do an analysis of who has the money
now? do you know where the money is now?
and she had nothing to say and I realized when I
askedher she didn't even know that she didn't know
where that money had gone until I asked the
question you know and that is because nobody
on the media is asking the question where is this
money who has this money now you know this is like
this is like you know you came home and you
found your house has disappeared and you're
worried about the fact that you dropped a tenner (£10)
on the floor this is an enormous amount of money
the government has given away it would be
£14,000for EVERY single adult in the country
if you don't have £14,000 more now than you
had at the beginning of Covid someone else has it
and the government has no idea who has that
money now and I think I think that this couldbe
a really profitable way for us to criticise the
government and also to spread the message
because it is clearly totally indefensible that they
do not know who has that 700 billion pounds
that's 14 000 pounds for every adult in the
country they've given it away and they do not know
who has it and if you ask them where's the 700
billion pounds there's literally nothing that
they can say because number one they have no
idea who has it. number two if they did know
they would have to tell you it's all gone to the
richest people in the country and they don't want
to tell you that and number three it's totally
indefensible that they don't know so I think
this is you know people message me a lot
recently saying what can we do to help and
I think the main thing that you can do is educate
yourself and spread the videos but if you want to
more directly criticise an attack this is the
thing you can do you know you can call into LBC
you can call into you can go on question time
you can go on you can post on your socials and
you can say listen the government has given that
700 billion pounds since the beginning of Covid
that is £14,000 pounds for every
single adult in the country
if we took that money back we could fix these
problems who has the money now? you can just say
to the conservative government 700 billion pounds
14 000 pounds per adult in the country who has it
now and there is nothing they can say so I think
this is you know when you have a big campaign
ultimately you do need to be able to boil it
down to very simple messages and very simple
sound bites that can spread around and I think
this is a sound like that that could really have
legs you know I think I've mentioned before in a
video I was in um I was in Parliament at a meeting
of MPs trying to convince them you know about the
importance of this money & it was a conservativeMP
that stood up and said who has that 450 billion
pounds and that that is a line of mine from an
earlier video when it was only 450 billion pounds
and that's coming back from a conservative MP
I think what that shows is this is a message that
if enough people say it could really get resonance
if we get enough people saying where's the 700
billion pounds where's the 700 billion pounds
you know that can appeal to people on both the
left and the right because it's a clear attack
that the government should know the government
should have an answer to that question they don't
so I think if you want to do something now and
you have the time and you have the energy now
get out there tell your friends tellyour
family post on your socials you know
call into the phone in shows go ontoquestion
time you know go on to whatever it is
whoever the guy Jeremy Vine that
does channel five in the mornings
call in and say listen the government's given
that 700 billion pounds since the beginning of
Covid who has that now because we need that the
NHS needs that ordinary families who can't pay
their bills need that and it's sitting in the bank
accounts of the richest people in the country so
what I realise I'm going on *BBC* is that
the government has a massive weakness here
and we the ordinary people of
the country who are struggling
um and people who should be criticising the
government in the media are not making the most
of it so here's a fantastic opportunity to attack
the government and force them to give us an answer
because if they look into it and actually
find out who has that 700 billion pounds
they will find that it's sitting in the
bank accounts of the richest people in
the country driving up the prices of the
things you need of the houses you need
and making it increasingly impossible for
ordinary families just to live their lives
so I think this is a great opportunity
and you know I've said in recent videos
I'm really planning to challenge the government
in the longer term here but I know there are
people that have the energy now to do
something now here is a real weakness
attack them tell your friends tell your family
they're giving out 700 billion pounds and they
don't even know who they've given it to they
do not even know who they've given it to
um and what I'm going to do now we're going
tofilm uh today a series of videos about the
£700 *billion* to help you understand better what
it is, who has it and how it's been affecting the
economy um I will keep you updated because that
number 700 billion because the government is now
having to pay so much money to support ordinary
families who often can't take care of themselves
because of this massive inflation caused by
that mass increase in cash by the government
the government is churning up more and more money
which means they will go more and more into debt
um so it will become 800 it'll become 900
eventually it'll become a trillion pounds
I'll keep you updated with that and I'll
keep you educated about what it means
um but it's a great opportunity you know use it
use it use it as a line post it on your Facebook
where's the where's the 700 billion pounds how
do we get it back because that is enough money
to solve this economic crisis and make
make life livable for ordinary families and
instead all it is doing is making the richest
people in the country unbelievably richer um so
yeah um we'll put the links in the description
for the appearance on BBC if you haven't seen
it um check it out I hope you enjoy it thanks
um you know the Channel's growing the voice
is growing and um hopefully eventually we
can we can stop this economic disaster and
that's because of your support so thank you
at the moment these guys are profiting from a
crisis that is going to keep our
economy in a slump for 50 years
there's one other thing they can do with that mass
amount of income they can buy your mom's house